have you considered all the submissions  that were made by both Council I make  the following order the case is  postponed to the 18th of April 2016 the  applicant is released on bail of ten  thousand Rand  and the amount of bail to be paid on  before the 11th of December 2015  before 16 hours at the office of the  registrar of this court further  conditions are the following one the  accused should appear at nine o'clock at  the scored on the postponement date and  every other date that this matter may be  postponed tuned to the today accused  submitted to the house arrest and may  leave the house between seven o'clock in  the morning and twelve o'clock midday  and is only allowed to travel within the  radius of 20 kilometers from the house  being house number two three zero  knowledge suite waterproof criteria in  the district of Houghton  you